Phil Heath welcome to the show what's
Happening good to see you man you look
great thank you thank you I appreciate
it thanks for having me on where did the
name the gift come from ah
well
it wasn't me okay it was an old roommate
that I had
um
I was already getting into the sport of
bodybuilding and he was like bro I have
the perfect nickname for you I was like
what is it he was like the gift I was
like seriously
you couldn't have picked a better name
than this like everybody's gonna be like
this guy's conceited he's arrogant he's
cocky this and that and the other he was
like no no no
think deeper
you're a former division one athlete
you're intelligent you're college
educated
you have a great physique and you know
how to speak to those audiences no one's
ever seen this
and I was like yeah man but I'm not even
Pro yet he goes doesn't matter he's like
I've been around because he had competed
before and he's he's actually from
Cyprus so I feel like him being European
and seeing more bodybuilders over there
and just in that area because of
bodybuilding being in a much bigger
sport overseas than it is here in the
states
um he just saw talent and he was like
this is you and your gift is to give
and then I was like Ah that's what I'm
going to use it as allow people to form
their own opinion initially
but that's based on their own stuff even
like me I was like oh yeah I think it's
this when really it's not it's about
what I can give to you a gift is
something I can give to you so then you
do what you have happiness you have joy
you have peace
um and I use that you know I use the
gifts that I have
and obviously in bodybuilding you know
just some incredible things but it was
about how I got there so then I can help
other people get to their you know
Champion Podium to go through their
levels of adversity to create better
moments of Triumph and I love the
nickname because I feel like we all have
a gift you have one I have one everyone
has one but we have to face those fears
as well
and understand that
we're only as good as
the tests
are we truly battle tested so it's like
what makes a person so smart what makes
a person
um you know we always see like oh well
Shaquille O'Neal hit a lot of free
throws by himself
but when the lights are on maybe not as
much right
um so you can't say like oh yeah I'm
this guy he's so badass it's like nah
man that gift is only as good as it's
been tested and it's been forged and
fortified over and over and over again
so for me it's just it takes on a
greater meaning than just like oh yeah
he thinks he's God's gift to this it's
like well no I can be if I pour into
myself and be willing to pour into
others so 17 years old you do this
interview and somebody asks you whether
or not you're going to make it into the
NBA you said I don't know about the NBA
oh you suck I know that I'm going to be
pro at something yeah where at the age
of 17 playing basketball is a five foot
980 pound guy yeah man where do you get
the self-belief from that you knew
because you despite people's assumptions
and I really want to get into this uh
it's not like you came from some
privileged background right it's not
like you had things
whatever the opposite of a silver
platter is right it was kind of that
scenario yeah
how do you develop self-belief at an age
where you only have minimal evidence
that something's going to come of it
well
understanding who is pouring into you
mom stepfather even my father poured
into me the coaches that I had poured
into me I had friends that are highly
competitive that you know forced me and
that's a key word is competitive nature
like I said I grew up in Seattle
Washington so you got to think at that
time I was born in 79 so just in my
neighborhood we had guys that are now
Pros in something I was neighbors with
uh Nate and Kevin Burleson I was
neighbors to Nate Robinson to Jamal
Crawford to Jason Terry to you know all
these different athletes right
and we talked about just guys that you
may recognize what about the other ones
that didn't make it so
my whole journey was about
finding who I am and not being afraid to
be who I am who I'm supposed to be and
having that Killer Instinct so I had a
coach by the name of Mike mathia and
he's still at my high school to this day
and he was probably the Bobby Knight of
basketball back then in high school
sports so like we'll yell at you we'll
curse at you we'll damn near hit you
upside the head right
totally different than what we could get
away with today but you know what it was
he just wanted to pull it out of you
like you know like some people can
really see
something within you and they know that
you're being really timid
and they can't whip yet but they want to
like shake you it's like the coach that
grabs the face mask of the guy and says
you can do this but I gotta yell I just
I'm losing my mind here you're messing
up and I know you can succeed so you
know at that given point in time
you know I got the opportunity to get a
division one scholarship to the
University of Denver sign that letter of
intent and then I was interviewed by The
Seattle Times and something just came
over me of like
okay you already beat the odds
you're you're five foot nine and I was
actually 155 pounds at the time and
but I already beat these odds I was a
guy that was already dunking a
basketball I was already running a four
three four you know I was doing I was a
state you know 100 meter track athlete
you know like
I already defeated a lot of odds like
but I had to be real and growing up in
Seattle you understand like what else is
around you so like you have basketball
but you also have Microsoft
you're seeing more millionaires come out
of Microsoft than they're on the NBA
so
I guess just through repetition in my
mind of always having something
uh to carry you beyond Athletics with
academics and stuff
um because that's my parents you know
they always force that on me always have
something to fall back on right
still to this day when I hear this I'm
like man I was prophetic that was not
for me man that was from Source above it
was like you he was telling the truth
you may not be Pro and basketball but
you're definitely going to be pro at
something and
I became that so I think a lot of people
hearing that plus the gift is the
nickname plus this illustrious career of
seven Olympia wins and and everything
else that you've achieved
would presume okay this guy
even if not everything was handed to him
psychologically he had all of the tools
ready from the beginning from before the
beginning to be able to do this can you
take me through
the day of your first show and what it
felt like to step out on stage ah well
the night before I asked all my
teammates I was still living in the
basketball house to not bring the party
back to the house of course they did so
about two in the morning you know I'm
over here being Awakening because I'm
living and then living in the basement
right
and I have forgiven them but you know
like
I have to be realistic they were going
to do it anyway right college girls you
know Red Cups you know it's just loud
music
but then
realizing I'm in it
I did all the work
remove myself from this situation go to
your car which is parked in the garage
sleep in there you still have a car you
can still sleep in there
woke up
and my friend Josh Crandall picked me up
and drove me to Boulder and I'm
literally telling them if I don't win
this damn thing man like I don't know if
I could do this again because
so much work
for
someone that could tarnish this it's not
like basketball games like where you can
go out you can drink you can party and
all this still go play in the game
bodybuilding no way and I learned
firsthand right so going in that first
competition you know walking in there
there's a couple things
of course I'm already tired from last
night and then also realizing that I
don't really know what I don't know so I
I just because I watched the
bodybuilding show in person and on a VHS
tape watching Ronnie Coleman win the 98
Olympia
it's different when you're there signing
up putting your name on there buying
your NPC card and all this other stuff
and now you're what are you going to do
not looking at yourself you're looking
at everybody else
and with you looking at everybody else
you forget who you are so much that
I'm like whoa this guy
oh he's got all these muscles and he's
vascular and this and that and the other
uh looks like he's on PDS or something
if my friend goes he is and I'm like
what I'm not like why didn't you tell me
this I was like man you like
what's going on and he goes you would
have never done it if I would have told
you that you were going against people
like this I was like what and he was
like just be chill man you look great
yeah sure yeah sure so of course I was
leading with a lot of anxiety and
whatnot so as I was walking on a stage I
thought
I need to address myself with a cloak
of like armor like of like strength
so that's when I was like you know
walking out like this like the
Terminator that's what I was thinking
about just walk out like the Terminator
like be strong be this when really I was
just looking like an idiot but I was
looking at uh looking like a guy that
was totally insecure
and that false bravado was definitely on
stage and everybody started laughing but
now I'm thinking oh my gosh I'm so
exposed
that they can see the false bravado too
oh man what's going on
it was the fact that they had seen
everybody else and I'm gonna win this
whole damn show but I don't know that
so I'm paying attention to the negative
beliefs more than the actual reality
that I've done the work I'm gonna win
this thing and now it's time to own all
of it so it wasn't until the point by a
lady that yelled out smile you're
beautiful
that I realized like oh wow okay now I
can
be in my own so I did the novice in the
open so then I could get more practice
because I recognized that if you only do
one category
you're up there for you know it feels
like an eternity but you're only up
there for like a minute and then you're
gone
I just you know the open I did the
novice and it opened so it all worked
out but after that prejudging I was like
holy smokes like how exhilarating is
this so then coming back then I had like
more of a smile and then I'm like
Swagger yes now I get to take the
Swagger from basketball
transfer that into bodybuilding all in
my first show
and I won that whole damn show man I I
beat them all down and what was really
cool was that that was the the same
evening that I met Jay Cutler as he was
in his pursuit of becoming Mr Olympia
so I remember taking the picture with
him backstage I was like so hey man what
do you weighing he's like I'm 290 and I
was like and I was like
well I'm 190. now what you know
so so we you know I'm sure you probably
have seen the photo with he and I you
know and that's how that came about so
the the lesson I love
from this is
there's a little bit of a juxtaposition
going on here which on one hand massive
capacity massive capability uh
self-belief but also crippling
insufficiency and that from somebody
that's won all of the World
Championships that's so well known
millions of followers inspired lots of
people I think it's so important for
normal people who as of yet haven't
fulfilled the dreams that they want to
to be able to understand
just how visceral the fear and the
embarrassment and the shame and the
uncertainty of any Glory at all right
and like
the the fact that it took some little
lady in the crowd to shout smile you're
beautiful to give you the license to
believe in work that you'd already done
right I think there's so much
it's that
as inspiring of a story as winning the
Olympia seven times I think because with
the future knowing where you were going
to go but seeing the lack of self-belief
it gives people who right now do not
have that degree of self-belief right
oh well it doesn't matter like even the
guy that was supposed to be the gift he
steps out on stage in these tiny pants
and he can't believe that he's gonna do
it and this lady has to bring him out of
his own head
ah yes I can do it yes we all need hope
we all need to in my opinion
um
know thyself
my friends got that tattooed on his back
he says he always wants Socrates behind
him yeah you have to you have to be in
that pursuit of knowing yourself
um
you play video games at all yeah a
little bit you know Mortal Kombat back
in the day you know as you go up the
levels who do you face your opponents oh
yes remember yes you would have to fight
yourself
so it's a beat the character you're
beating yourself so that means you have
to know everything about you to be
better than you
well ultimately
the the most difficult enemy that you're
going to encounter is going to be
yourself yeah I think a lot of the time
I got this story about Winston Churchill
so
um
um Churchill is showing a young MP
around the houses of Parliament and this
young MP it is the bathrooms and this is
where we go for lunch and this is
whatever whatever right and imagine
Churchill's sort of bloviating around
anyway
gets down into uh the House of Lords and
you've got the benches you know the
distance between the two benches is the
distance of two broadswords held out at
arm's length right for precisely the
reason that they wanted it and anyway
this young guy who's probably full of
himself and full of testosterone comes
in he starts gesturing the other side
the other benches he starts referring to
them as the enemy and Churchill turns to
him and he says that's the opposition
Dear Boy the enemies behind you
and this isn't
literally what he meant but figuratively
I think what he means is that Your Own
Worst Enemy is always the one that is
playing on your team
they the person that's inside of your
head knows your weaknesses they know all
of the buttons to push that you wouldn't
dare say to even your worst enemy and
you will consistently deploy that to you
when you've tried your hardest when you
had Noble intentions and fell short
despite it not being your fault and you
are able to treat yourself like the
worst piece of
in a way that nobody else would and if
they did they would be out of your life
in a moment right so I think that yes
seeing yourself as both your greatest
potential fan and supporter and also
your worst potential enemy well you have
to you have to uh and I agree I mean you
have to expose the lies
expose all the lies
that you tell yourself now now let's be
clear
we have what thousands and thousands of
years of DNA stored within us so some of
those stories aren't yours
it could be your parents could be
grandparents Uncle some something right
expose those lies man
I've learned now you know uh growing up
that okay
I am good enough why am I talking down
to myself don't I want a championship
moment don't I don't I deserve that and
all I have to do is give myself
permission to be me
and may I may fail
but what drives me is that a lot of the
time we're always oh what's my calling
and even in that moment on that stage
right where I still remember the lady's
name her name was Margaret
she gave me permission
to be me
where are we giving ourselves permission
to be our best version of self
you have to give yourself permission
every day you just woke up every day and
then didn't even first of all you didn't
even think your body for putting up with
your ass
so I should give myself permission and
almost declare it every day like I
declare that I'm gonna go out here and
make a difference in my life I declare
that I'm gonna go do this cardio that I
freaking don't like I declare that I'm
going to eat better I declare that I'm
actually going to
look at my wife in the eye and tell her
something sweet
pick up the kids
you know pet the dog whatever say hello
to that one employee that you know what
typically I don't really like them
but today
I'm gonna do something different because
I'm going to change the pattern
I'm going to change the pattern I'm
going to make it work for me because
this life is worth living so I give
myself permission to be great and I
think what happens is
by giving yourself permission other
people see that and they get frustrated
because they're like how did he figure
it out um because all I did was answer
the call to my own greatness your ass is
still wondering where the call is coming
from it's already there just pick up the
phone and say I I accept
when we don't accept that calling
it then goes to somebody else someone
else someone else got hey who's gonna
pick up that phone
so I'm gonna get that
well it's you for you Phil no oh
it's for me if I don't pick it up in
time the way this works it's going to go
to somebody else and then they're gonna
get the championship moment and
you and I both have seen this whether
it's been happening in our lives and
someone else's life when they don't pick
it up if you don't pick it up
oh that's when you don't get the
girl
you know you don't get the date for prom
that you really want it you settle for
something else because you're
indecisiveness because you're fear you
didn't get the job you didn't go to the
school you didn't get anything that you
really wanted and now the person that
had half as much as the talents as you
that just took a risk on themselves and
gave themselves permission to succeed
and if they fail so what
you're hating on them
you're talking about them you're
saying oh yeah must be nice
must be nice you get to go on the
vacations why does he have to oh he's a
kiss ass
he's this he's that no you dummy it was
you and your inability to execute
so by me seeing that in myself and being
a wuss I had to eliminate that
right away because I recognize in
certain areas of my life where I did
stand up and say I'm gonna do this what
was the outcome I killed it if I go up
to the squat rack and I see 450 pounds
or whatever it is and I'm like
I've already lost I have to go into it
knowing that I should win because I've
trained for this now I haven't trained
for that
there's danger there's extreme danger
with this and I shouldn't do it
but if I train for this I should know
that yep it's heavy it's going to be
heavy
but I'm gonna take it for a ride you
ready and when I pound that chest oh I'm
ready
and it's me reminding myself who the
hell I am and that way I can then and
only then impose my will onto someone
else you can't impose your will on
someone else if you don't know who the
hell you are and that's what makes the
Michael Phelps slapping the freak of
water to the Usain Bolt
you know that it's all effective
Michael Jordan the only guy to ever have
his tongue out while he's driving to the
basket and dunk on your face
to fly
to the Bo Jackson's that man I mean if
that guy never got hurt but did so much
breaking bats this guy was like
a demigod and was never afraid of being
who he was
so that's why I always admire
those people
that believe in themselves and you're
telling me that they didn't have moments
where they're having that tactical
mindful in their head like saying you
can't do this Phil come on man you don't
know anything oh you want to be an
entrepreneur you want to run a business
you don't know that no dude it's
not like I didn't know anything when I
picked up a basketball the first time or
played a piano or played the freaking
Nintendo game I didn't know
but I had passion behind it I was
curious about it and I put effort into
it and I was passionately present with
others so that
you know I could yield some good wins
and uh I could easily say I've had more
wins than losses and I've had
I'd say more than 95 of those wins come
from extreme competitive nature
derived by positive belief like
you could not be around me at the
Olympia and say hey Phil you think
you're gonna win this year
get the out of here why are you
even still standing here you would not
ask a mother that is getting ready to
give birth hey you ready to
what are we talking about
so you know a lot of people can only
understand so much of this right but in
their own lives I think this is the most
relatable thing
being in relation to like you know
obviously I would tell myself Phil
you're so misunderstood because of what
you achieved and it's that well now I
recognize it's about what's in here and
what's in here that I can give and this
is part of this conversation is that you
have to give yourself extreme permission
to just learn and be curious and ask
questions and say man I don't know man
Chris can you you know you've been
podcasting you've been doing all these
episodes I'm just getting started like
what do you think the three things that
I should be doing right now do you see
anything in me because I believe that
these are my qualities and do you think
those qualities can be applicable into
this and just sitting back and shutting
the hell up and letting people speak
right in other news this episode is
brought to you by element element is a
tasty electrolyte drink mix with
everything that you need and nothing
that you don't it's a healthy
alternative to sugary electrolyte drinks
and it is the best way that I have
started my moaning every single day for
over three years now it contains a
science-backed electrolyte ratio of
sodium potassium and magnesium with no
sugar no coloring no artificial
ingredients or any other junk you
adenosine system that caffeine acts on
isn't active for the first 90 minutes of
the day but your adrenal system is and
salt act on your adrenal system so if
you want to be more awake want to
regulate your appetite curb cravings and
have better brain health this is the way
to start your day head to drink lmnt.com
modern wisdom to get a free sample pack
of all eight flavors with your first box
plus there is a no BS no questions asked
refund policy so you can buy it 100
risk-free that's drinklmnt.com
modern wisdom there's a
something came up when you were talking
about your coach that perhaps from a
bygone era would have grabbed you by the
Scruff oh my God I told you to do that
yeah uh quote from a friend who I was
with yesterday says uh cry to someone
who pities you rather than believes in
you and it makes me that
um
treating self-love or or believing that
self-love is holding yourself to a
higher standard than anybody else is
such a beautiful reframe of saying okay
what do you want like what do you want
in this moment things are hard the diet
is difficult this business you're trying
to get off the ground the the job that
you're trying to go for it's not
happening what do you want do you want
sympathy or do you want me to have
higher standards for you than you do
thank you do you want me to hold you to
higher standards than you do because I
believe in you why do you think I'm
holding you to high standards do you
want me to hold you to low standards
yeah and they wonder why
they were getting yelled at by their
teachers
getting the call see something in you I
used to get calls home
from the teachers right once a quarter
it was it was like clockwork Phil's
being disruptive
I was probably being disruptive because
I had to explain this to my mom I was
like I'm being disruptive probably
because I'm getting my work done first
because I'm like wanting to get this
done first so I can be left alone but
then I like turn around I'm like hey
what's up man what's going on you know
what I mean and I get caught but then I
used to tell I remember on more than one
occasion
I would after they I we'd get the call
and my parents would sit me down and
just you know they ground you
so the parents sit me down and they
ground me right
you said you wouldn't do this anymore we
gotta you know Punishment No Nintendo
know this you know you can't go out with
France whatever it is
I go up to the teacher and I'm like
seeking retribution man I'm like hey man
why'd you call my parents man you know
what I mean like not that I could
threaten an adult but I'm like but but
Timmy over here is you know throwing
pencils and paper and this and that and
the other and I remember this happening
on more than one occasion and the
teacher would say
meet me after class I gotta say
something to you and you know what it
was we don't expect something from him
or from her but I see something in you
that I'm and your mom told me to ride
you
so I'm going home mom man like what's
going on and I realized like that is a
form of love of saying like hold my kid
to the higher standard because obviously
they see something that I don't see what
do they see they see talents someone who
believes in you someone that believes
you so right so therefore
oh you gotta you got a three eight why
don't you get a 4.0 come on Mom it's
like no but why not
why can't you and why can't you do it
for just more than one quarter why can't
you do it for more than one semester why
can't you do it forever because we know
that you can't right well you've already
proven it if you can sit there and play
video games for three hours you can do
you can read a book so this is this is
something that I think is really
important to drive home
the better that you get the better that
you realize that you can become
and in that way the more
that you work
the more painfully you become aware of
your deficiencies right and I think this
is anybody that feels like they have
potential
the real pain in life is getting to the
end of it and realizing that you left
something on the table I think that I
had unfulfilled potential I could have
done more and I and I didn't right
so in some regards having a a high
potential is a blessing and a curse
because the standard has now been said
or at least the ceiling has now been set
and it's a case of okay how close of
that are you gonna get and
what that's high that's really really
high ceiling
that causes discomfort in people well at
some point
for me
I had to realize there is none
and I'm the one that said there's no
ceiling anymore
but with that
comes with the unknown and now you have
to do the real work right so let's just
say winning my first Olympia in 2011
you know you see all those wise in the
road and you're like oh like I did
all this stuff and now it all makes
sense
all those things got me to this moment
right here okay
but next week
I got three days of photo shoots and I
gotta get on a fight to India to go
compete against the same people that
just beat the last thing I need is to
let up off the gas and give these guys
an opportunity to knock me off because
theoretically they'd say
oh man Phil got lucky at the Olympia now
I gotta like solidify the win
so how many people think of life like
like that of saying I need to solidify
this win if I was
uh
if I was salesman of the quarter why not
of the year and if I wasn't last year
why not this year and it just goes into
that you gamify your own process you
can't expect everybody to care about
your success is more than you
but a lot of the time it happens because
you see you know your parents these
potential coaches teachers especially in
the beginning when you don't have the
self-belief right so at some point you
have to remove that and say well I get
that and I appreciate that how about I
prove myself rightful ones well what
does that mean well let me just dream
and let's visualize
all of it let's visualize what abundance
really is
and realize
that there's a pain tolerance involved
but how do I handle that pain talk to me
about your relationship with pain
well my relationship with pain
oh man I mean we don't have enough hours
but I can give you an example of how
I deal with it well you could easily
Super Hyper focused like going to the
gym let's say you know uh breakups make
great bodybuilders those type of things
right we already know that
but I'll give you one for instance I've
shared this story you probably already
know it but you know uh a few years back
like like eight years ago or nine years
ago I was actually guest posing in
Cleveland Ohio for Dave Lieberman did a
great event you know I'm posing I'm
having fun having a great speech can't
remember everything but I remember
getting like a standing ovation it was
very rare like people like yeah like
this is awesome what he was saying and
pouring into us they're not getting a
limo to go back to the hotel where I
rinse all the tanning off and I go do a
meet and greet with like 100 people
inside of a restaurant
I found out that my father had passed
away
and I had the phone on speaker and the
driver's like uh Mr Heath and I said
just slow it down a little bit slow down
the the drive
if you don't mind so I get to the room
and I'm like
no tears
does that make me callous trying to
process this
it's like well you already knew that
your dad was sick so this should come
with no surprise you know it's It's
upsetting
opening up the the laptop and going on
Facebook
and then realizing that that's not the
way of handling things because that's
how everyone else handles things and
you're not them
and you're not giving yourself a time
period of digesting what just happened
that doesn't mean that you're going to
burst out in tears that doesn't mean
you're going to yell but I gave myself
permission I felt like oh I need to give
myself some time to kind of like just
sit with this and ask myself what does
this mean you know what it you know what
I got uh
it's like John C Maxwell talks about the
whisper when you're in silence you get a
Whispers usually from above right or
your Consciousness you know like
something that voicing your hair you get
a whisper
it says go to work
you got work to do and that sounds like
my father right so I'm like okay so I go
in the shower I get everything ready and
all I did was do a nice gesture I called
up my best friend put them on FaceTime
and your friends kind of know you so the
minute I did he was like No And I was
like yep
tequila please cheers to my pops that's
that by now the the promoters heard what
was going on they gave me every
opportunity to just walk back to the
hotel room get a meal sent out and uh
call it a night and get on the next
flight home
I said no I'm good I just needed this
moment just make sure there's no
pictures you know just me and my boy
we're just talking and I did that and I
did my job because guess what I'm not
the first person to go through this
and I look at it as a badge of honor of
how I handle things in battle tested
moments so I never was in the military
but I always think of that like people
that get those Stars those badges and
stuff they had to go through something
this is my opportunity
to say you know what I went through this
and now I can help somebody else go
through theirs could you imagine going
through these things so you talk about
pain absolutely I mean yeah I was upset
but there was no time for that yet
what I've learned is like you have to
still give your uh Body Mind and Spirit
an opportunity to let those feelings
come
and you can't always push them
underneath and I did that throughout a
lot of my career so I do understand pain
of
death With My Father his wife
um passed like two years later now I got
my half brother
High functional autistic
perfectly fine as far as like as
Scholastic achievement is concerned
Super Hyper focused and that graduated
high school at 15 Phi Theta Kappa at 16.
but now do I have to change my why to
make sure that he's taken care of
financially right huh
dealing with a divorce at the same time
of running a business that's crumbling
having the ridicule go online because
now I'm the Tom Brady of bodybuilding
realizing also that I'm now chasing you
know the J cutlers the the dorians and
now Arnolds of Olympia championships
and saying why am I doing this and
having the pain of just the physical
torture that I had to put myself through
and I put myself through it on purpose
because I knew in the end
it all be worth it so I say my pain
tolerance I think is is very very high
you know I went through divorce death
business ridicule publicly
um those are all relatable things but I
did it all while still kicking a lot of
freaking ass on Olympia stage
and that made me more powerful on
Olympia station when I walk out I'm like
you guys have not gone through this I
know your life right because on social
media we all kind of share a lot and
some people over share so now I really
know what's going on with you I'm like
oh you haven't gone through this
therefore you didn't have to do some
self work
you you have a some of these guys had a
perfect life right I'm like man you
didn't have these struggles and and
you can't even diet
you can't even train you have a whole
Entourage picking up your weights and
stuff I train by myself 99 of the time
oh I know who I am
like how Dorian games would say they
could never out train me they could
never out that's why they couldn't beat
me I felt the same way I outprepared
them
I out motivated myself when I'm looking
at myself in the mirror I'm like yeah
you're here you're here to work
and you're gonna get this job done and I
call myself MFR a million probably a
zillion times because I also knew
what Legacy really means what Legacy
really means is when you're in the dirt
or in some Mausoleum or whatever
people have some incredible things to
say about you because of what you not
just one but what you provided them and
they knew that even your
the biggest hater
is actually
one of your greatest sound boards when
you're gone
because of what you did
so when I decided to not compete
those biggest haters that were just dry
I mean they weren't driving me and
saying I actually enjoyed it
they were the ones that said man I wish
you came back because I don't see the
level of competitiveness in this sport
ever again and man I wish I could have
appreciated him
and I look at that and I say
that's life sometimes we don't
appreciate them until it's gone but it's
really cool to know that those people
that just despised your greatness
really
embraced your greatness in all essence
because it was a reminder Phil he's come
to Olympia there's a standard
I could let's say I came back next year
not this creating me okay right the
internet's listening right it's gonna oh
yeah yeah but let's just say I did or
did the Arnold Classic or something like
that people would get excited and some
people say oh we can't do this and that
but then some there's going to be a
large majority that says but what if he
did what if he isn't hurt what if he
isn't this what if he is who he is
they say well it's over it's not just
like oh he has a chance it's like no
it's freaking over and that was because
of the standards that I created for a
long stretch of time it was not luck
and that's why I loved speaking uh
public speaking talking to different
corporations and talking to c-suite
Executives about stamina which is a word
that is never used whether it be in
business or in athletics is very rarely
used how often do you hear the word
stamina
they don't they talk about Peak
Performance but Peak Performance just
goes soon and it may go down let's go
Peak Performance and hold it
that'd be muscular endurance but I like
stamina
you know stamina in the bedroom stamina
in the gym stamina you know like stamina
reading a book you know but having Peak
Performance with enough stamina you are
freaking Unstoppable and you are now a
machine and I and I just I love people
that are having high standards of
themselves because they're always having
an endless pursuit of personal
excellence
and it weeds out the bullshitters it
weeds out the fakers that we see online
we we see so much of it right now and I
think it's our job to
do exceptional work on ourselves so then
the consumer of content will realize
he actually has proof in his performance
based on the journey that he can share
that he shared because I mean your
life's true I mean you know
you're a great Storyteller because
you've done work and you've had
experiences some of the younger people
haven't gone through that yet so we
can't talk about things yet and a young
Anakin Skywalker cannot talk
in retrospective like who he was at
Darth Vader before he passed he didn't
know who he was until the end my job is
to
check check in with myself you know what
I'm saying and different chapters of my
life let's check in
let's Journal a little bit
let's actually use a pen and paper
because we know the neurological
connection let's do that let's look in
each other's eyes when we speak let's
not do this at the dinner table
but let's also give ourselves permission
again to to acknowledge our failures and
trim the fat seriously when possible
so you start off with this
the gift nickname it sticks with you
it's got multiple meanings it's lay it
and then there's a really interesting
period sort of 2012 to I guess kind of
2014 15 where the dream killer yeah
comes in what did you think about having
that name
I loved it I actually love that one more
than the gift sometimes because that's
that uh
you know they say Kobe Bryant black
mamba Black Cat from Michael Eric Jordan
is it you say or is it Usain Bolt the
bolt you know like all these nicknames
you know and dream killer actually came
about because of the fans
after Generation Iron was published I
was getting ready for the 2013 Mr
Olympia and I had a feeling that that
was my opportunity to close the door on
Kai green this just close the door
because when the movie would come out
and if I lose then they're going to
watch the movie even though it was based
on 2012
know what game you're playing Phil the
way people see things on TV they may not
watch 2013. they may think that's a
previous show now you're not Champion
anymore now that movie just makes you
look like you oh he fell off
so I I put that added pressure on myself
and I stepped up to the challenge and I
said you know what you're going to train
harder you're going to train smarter
you're going to you're going to do
whatever it takes to
you know beat the living out of
them on stage you know you're gonna and
and then I was like well how do you do
that it's like all right well
sometimes you got to train angry
take 2011 take 2012 merge them
2013 and I had one called out that year
right
well like I said after generation nine a
lot of people had opinions about me that
I felt it was uh
very interesting
because it was a docu drama and it
wasn't a documentary so take me through
this experience of filming generation
nine so for the people that aren't
familiar yeah there's from the past
originally Pumping Iron with Arnold and
then they actually did was it total
rebuild yeah so there's two words right
it was two names The Comeback and total
rebuild right yeah yeah it's like
different but I think uh pumping iron's
actually free available on uh YouTube
premium or whatever at the moment so
anyway they do this and then
the
I guess you would say the progeny of
that production company decided to come
back and show the new generation of
bodybuilders and the key rivalry in this
is yourself and Kai Greene yeah take me
through before it happens what are you
told about it what's the experience and
what happens after it was pretty much
exactly what you just said it's like we
already know pump and iron we're pretty
much doing this for the new era failure
the champion your role as the champion
you're defending for the first time
that's pretty much it we're going to
follow you around they literally parked
an RV outside of my house for a week and
they were in my house at the gym driving
with me doing everything a lot of a lot
of hours of content obviously that still
hasn't been published you know maybe
they come up with a director's cut later
on of me screwing around in the gym
telling jokes talking you know like
different things
uh
I loved it because I I also looked at it
as an opportunity to maybe step outside
of bodybuilding and going to Hollywood
kind of like what Arnold did prematurely
you know because Arnold did that film
toward the end where I'm at the
beginning
but I was like hey if they pull you away
baby you'd still be young enough to come
back right
so I go into the show knowing that I
have to win so I did that
and then obviously when it came out it
was it was it was good I mean I I
remember seeing the two movie premieres
in LA and New York and I was like man
this is dope this is exciting and I'm
looking good right now so I know I'm
gonna win and I remember my coach honey
Rambo pulls me aside he goes this isn't
good I go what are you talking about he
goes no it's a good film
but I think people are going to look at
you as the villain
the way they
they made it seem like you had
everything
and I know you're a brand you worked for
everything and they made it seem like
you just you know you're driving the
Bentley you got the house you got two
houses you got that you know what I mean
while Kai is living in this like which
is that complete like okay you
have this house but like
I can't even speak on another man's
income but like you just do you know I'm
a very logical person I'm like
the fans all they have to do is say well
this guy won the Arnold Classic like a
couple times man like this guy's not
broke he's got a weird contract he's got
a muscle muscle mass contract you think
he
I know it New York prices are expensive
but come on you know what I mean 300
square foot right I'm like well maybe
that's just he keeps that as a studio
and maybe has another place which I
think we both know that that was
probably the case
oh Phil you have to realize
they didn't tell you
that this is a docudrama
all right
so now just like I said when it came out
uh they had a viewing after the Olympia
after I just won my third title could
you imagine I go in there and people are
actually like talking
so I stand up you know with a microphone
on my hand I go hey how many you guys
liked it and somebody was like yeah and
they're like I was like you guys thought
I was an people were like I'm
like whoa like let's let's but for me I
was at that point I was like why
huh
and then I just accepted it I was like
you know what okay I can't you know I'm
not here to change people's opinions of
me man like you know that that takes too
much time energy
you know that's when social media really
started you know started formulating and
stuff going to 2014 I'm like just let
your proof be how you win bro they just
win
but now you got to train really freaking
angry
and if they want that I'm
gonna give it to him you want a villain
I'll give you a villain
because I can take it
every hero became a villain in someone's
eyes you know Hulk Hogan The Rock like
they all became the heel at some point
but it's the but I I was like yeah but
you know what it was remember the movie
was uh
Batman Begins or whatever and he became
like Dark Knight whatever and what do
they say uh when it was like at the end
of the movie and it was like after
Harvey Dent got you know messed up and
they said well why did he make it look
like it was him and Commissioner Gordon
tells the kid because he can take it
I was like Phil you're the only dude
that can take it
all these guys can't take it they're all
insecure they're all like if the if the
lights were shining on them and them
being misunderstood and having
everyone's opinions be spread on them
they couldn't handle it
only the best Phil
only the best can handle it only the
best can handle the scrutiny
you're going to be the greatest because
now they're looking at you with a
harsher lens it is not
10 times 25 times 50 times is 250 times
magnification only problem is that sucks
is that now I'm being judged that way
like 250 times magnification back in
school with the teachers so now I'm like
okay that's the shitty part but just
embrace it just use it so I created the
shirts I made I made the merge made a
bunch of money off of it and and played
that part and
that was like my Alter Ego is like so
you guys want the dream killer now
and that's when I started being able to
in my opinion make people afraid and I
loved it because I said you smiling too
you know like yeah because we all have a
dark side
and it was about me having that
controlled aggression in the gym and
even with fans I mean I was never rude
with fans you know I'm saying like I
meet with them I did the Make-A-Wish
Foundation stuff I did the Autism
Awareness events and all those things
now that may be overshadowed because of
someone's opinion about Generation Iron
but again Phil you have to learn
that the people who you aspire to be
have the same thing
but 10 times worse a politician has it a
million times worse right uh an actor
has it worse I know actors that have
played some great films and they people
see them on the street and curse them
out because they were a buddy right and
they and imagine and so I'm like
laughing I'm like yeah
these guys don't have that common sense
but I'm like but but that means that
that great of an actor so just just use
it to your advantage man and um
the problem is is like how I I can't lie
like
sometimes being the dream killer is so
fascinating
that is hard to push them away tuck them
away
so then you know like my trainer said
like in an interview what a year ago I
was talking about like Phil Heathrow
John Wick
a bodybuilding I'm like don't kill his
dog just don't just don't kill his dog
don't don't talk about his wife or
something like that it's like you know
talk to me about how you reflect on your
relationship with Kai Greene because
people yeah the greatest rivalry in
bodybuilding and it's then the stakes
are raised the generation and it's the
Inception of social media right talk to
me about that relationship with Kai
Greene I think it's
I think it is the greatest rivalry I
think it's bigger than Jay and Ronnie's
just because they were friends we
weren't and I think we wanted to be
friends Kai and I but I feel like
because of we want us both wanting
something so freaking bad and during the
social media era one camp
the other camp they're talking so much
and we can see the chatter
that it kind of made it look like so you
don't like me Chris okay uh it's like
high school you know I mean like you
talking and then all you do is look
at me weird and I'm like all right
what's up so
I know that Kai had to play
psychological warfare because this is
bodybuilding it's not MMA it's not
boxing you know like it's not even
basketball or football right
it's just
a person lifting weights and dieting and
doing heavy amounts of cardio and posing
that it's hard to impose your will on
someone physically
so you got to figure out how he can beat
me so for him to start a fight you know
like in 2014 flipping the hair and all
this other stuff I don't blame them
people used to get mad at me for like
accepting it like in my like a friend's
Circle they're like man like here's cool
but I said I expected it they're like
how did you why'd you expect this I said
listen it all started the damn press
conference
but I knew he was going to do some I
didn't know what I was going to respond
by saying the three facts and all this
stuff he'd signed his name oh yeah Mr
Olympia yeah he started doing your like
over your face or something yeah yeah
yeah so we have a we have an Olympia
poster that comes out every year so when
we get our Olympia credentials you know
our per diem all that good stuff we have
to sign a bunch of merchandise one of it
is like a big ass poster that we give
out all the VIP holders so you know of
course you know I'm like it's front and
center so people are going to sign like
maybe the leg or this and that this fool
like on the face I'm like oh it's like
that Annie wrote Mr Olympia I'm like
okay how many times did he do it for
like a whole row of them I'm like oh
he's trying to send a message
so uh you know basketball mentality
comes out right now it's like oh this is
oh I love it the disrespect I love it
like now I get to
make this more intentional
and he has no idea what I look like
he's then going to try to probably say
something at this press conference why
because that's what I would do
know thyself know your opponent know how
to respond versus react see when you
don't play through these things and when
you only get fixated on how much food
and water do I drink and yes I have to
do this mundane stuff you need to work
on the mind of figuring out all the
different permutations that can exist
all the different scenarios that can
happen
that way you know how to handle yourself
in anything that comes towards you so
I get I gave him what he needed at the
press conference and he had nothing to
say after that and that's when I knew
the only thing left was for him to try
to do something physical and I handled
it well and
unfortunately that was like the end of
that prejudging yeah they split you
apart right yeah Dennis wolf in between
you yeah no one's walking through him I
mean in a way it was it was it was effed
up because I'm like
we're not performing now
um and it was a big adrenaline dump as
well for he and I both I know he
probably had it because his sister took
to me you're on stage you've worked
toward this thing for ages Generation
Iron is out yeah it's already out for
the second year yeah so you've got the
Rivalry is not only private it's public
yep you've had him signing his name on
your face literally
on posters you've had him talking
at the press conference yep and then you
get on stage and he's got this like
Predator ponytail thing that he whips
and hits you with and then has something
to say and then you sort of jostle
against each other and then there's this
legendary photo of you finally turning
and looking and it's you guys face to
face on the Olympic stage
what's that
emotional dump like with all of this
pressure on all of this preparation
coming up it's it felt like high school
when everybody's like fight fight fight
fight and then
you're basically getting into it and
then there and then there was the fans
energy that I felt that got calm because
all you could hear is
if you if you if you were there you
would be able to hear Steve weinberger's
voice get elevated and they turned the
music up louder because they wanted I
guess they were trying to drown out the
crowd noise like like it was cheering it
on because they kind of were
and then I realized
two big ass dudes oiled up and
posing trunks you're supposed to fight
nah you're not paying enough for this
nah exactly someone's getting the draws
pulled out you know hey it ain't
happening that's not the fight that I
signed up for so uh let's go ahead and
calm this down and get back to work
but you're right so
I realized right then and there the fans
really messed this up
because the fans were egging us on for
two two years now
because you got to think
uh 2012 there was a moment where Kai and
I are posing you know you do the back
shots and I used to always kind of like
that was in 2013. so 2012. we're doing a
back shop
and I look back no I look like this and
I'm kind of like looking at the glutes
because it's kind of like letting the
judges know he ain't got what I got
so I was like come on man oh you stopped
him on the ass I I kind of like touched
like touch his lower back or something
like that slapped him on the ass and
then uh so then he was he there's a
picture of him like looking at he was
going to punch me yes yes so no one
remembers this right but but you know
what it did that was the no Flinch with
Matt Barnes versus Kobe
so I was like yes I got him yep now I'm
in his head
he wants to like you know all right 2013
Arnold Classic uh Madrid
that's when we're doing this
and he's just pissed and I'm like got
him we'll get back to talking to Phil in
one minute but first I need to tell you
about factor I get asked all the time
about how to build and maintain muscle
and the most important thing the first
thing you need to do is ensure you are
getting one gram per kilo of body weight
in protein every single day but as you
know if you have ever tried to cook
anything ever consistently you'll stick
to your Macros finding whole food
healthy meals you can have conveniently
every single day is difficult this is
where Factor comes in they're fresh
never frozen meals are designed by
registered dietitians and arrive ready
to heat and eat in minutes it requires
zero prep so if you're someone that says
I'd love to hit my protein numbers but I
never have time to cook prep takes so
long and I hate doing it this is the
solution for you so if you want to make
an improvement to your diet this August
you can get factor and start eating
better without the hassle head to the
link in the description below or go to
factor meals.com mw50 and use the code
mw50 for 50 off your first order at
checkout that's Factor meals.com mw50
and mw50
a checkout how do you think so it seems
like your ability to deal with
discomfort both
psychological physical
it's balanced I I think discomfort in
the time but it doesn't seem to Echo you
don't seem to ruminate beyond what you
need to to learn the lessons right
what do you know about how Kai felt
during this rivalry well he had to feel
I mean of course he's going to feel
robbed right because he's going to think
well
I look good too I put in so much effort
I've gone through so many levels so many
levels of adversity I deserve this
and I'm only one person away
one person away and then once I got him
out of my way I can have everything I've
ever wanted
I get to now every time I see Phil Heath
I see success I see what life is
presented him and what he's been able to
experience and I can't have the same
thing without going through him I got to
go through him
so there's a level of empathy I have
even now like I I realized I've spoken
to him yeah we've you know it's very
interesting is that we've had a few
conversations Kai Greene gets credit for
me because he was the first athlete in
the ifbb to call me after I lost in
2018.
and he was the only one
he was the only one that picked up the
phone and we talked at length
and that made me feel I mean
it wasn't like an emotional like like
I'm gonna cry it was more like
the person who knows me the most is the
one that I battled against the most
right
and he basically gave me some some much
needed words of like Phil they didn't
beat
Phil that I know they beat an injured
one
you're still
the best ever and to hear that
you know it made me feel good because
well in my opinion he was right
and he would he would know that because
he was he knew who what he was going
against and he knows that
man if if
imagine the amount of stress Phil had to
go through and I need to I need to reach
out to him and let him know like
everything's cool man you're gonna be
okay like and he's already he was mind
you 2018 I mean he was already four
years or three years removed because
either the Arnold Australia I believe in
um so he had already started that
transition away yeah and I had yet to
decide if that was what I wanted to do
so he was giving me an option on that
phone call of saying Phil now you're at
this point where
you don't have to prove yourself to
anyone
um
the judges can do whatever the hell they
want
you've solidified yourself
like I respect you and I thought damn
like
thank you and you know since then I mean
we've always had that you know casual I
mean now granted during the conversation
there was still Fu Phil and this and
that the other you know just because we
can't it's like
we can't be like Hallmark cards and
roses and we still got to be like I
respect you but you man you know
what I mean like and I'm cool with it I
saw Kai last year at the gym shark event
here in California and we both were just
like there's just that Vibe and we both
know that it's cool it's cool to be like
him saying you Phil Heathen I said
you Kai you know what I mean like
it's all and you know it's funny it's
sweet yeah it's like a term of
endearment and fans though like when
they see us in the room like everyone
would get quiet oh they think they're
still yeah and there isn't there's more
respect than anything because
that's what it should be but it always
was it's just that when you're battling
we respected the game when when I don't
think people have seen
I mean outside of a a j and Ronnie
situation two highly competitive people
that were boisterous about what they
wanted we were extremely voicerous and
if that meant that we ruffled the
feathers of the opposite team we didn't
give a
we just didn't we couldn't because we
needed their support we needed those
fans sometimes to remind us like yeah
man like okay we got this I mean I would
see people arguing at the Olympia Expo
over who's going to win and this that
Kai's fans coming up talking trash and
I'm like
remember posing in the audience and
people would you know say stuff and I'm
like
what happened to your boy you know and
then the fans like Oh and it was like
the so it was like some WWE uh stuff
correct and as much as some fans want to
make it seem like for me I was being
like extremely like negative or whatever
I was playing along just like them
because at the same time I mean we're
providing Sports entertainment
and if I can have a little fun with a
troll online I'm gonna do it you know
like and and uh because I should have
fun I should have fun with this this is
great like it's really cool that I can
have certain types of powers that I can
literally transform my physique into
something that no one that could ever
imagine well think about it this way as
well that it's not just
the enjoyment of being the Sportsman but
it's the enjoyment of being
a personality as well of you know
developing a brand and if the brand for
a short amount of time is to be the
villain like no one no one looks back
Floyd Mayweather you know like played
for a very long time they did a
he fought
on Cinco de Mayo and called it Cinco de
Mayweather yeah and came out with the
sombrero yep yeah and just a
professional troll before the word troll
exists that's right right do it and now
looking back people I mean some of his
most recent fights maybe his padded his
right record a little bit but uh I think
that playing that heel and doing that is
I don't know if you have the psychology
to be able to absorb it yeah and stay
Economist yeah I think that
that makes for a much more exciting it
the greatest rivalry in bodybuilding
right it wouldn't have existed had you
not have had the Rivalry yeah right it's
not it wasn't because of the bodies
maybe it was in some regards
but it was because of the personalities
yeah that was what made it happen and it
drove
competitiveness
how much better do you think you became
because of Kai Greene oh extremely I
mean every year it was like
you get to see him guest pose on the
circuit and you're like oh did you
respect his his physique oh of course I
I knew
I respected it all the time the problem
is is that just because I respect it and
I have an opinion of it
like parts of me was like gosh all they
had to do
was be who he was when he did those
Arnold Classics and the 2012 Olympian
and he might have got me
maybe that's the difference because he
got bigger and he was trying to imagine
uh manage too much size Kai green is
probably probably if not the most dense
bodybuilder we have ever seen
that includes Coleman like density wise
because you got to think you're shorter
than Coleman weighed as much nearly as
much
and it was like deep separate deep Cuts
Like deep deep like very like slabs of
beef like when he does the pulling the
elbows back and you see the Christmas
tree thick straight in lats
um just very deep now you like the chest
size and the depth with that and the
shoulder so that's why Coleman would get
the edge but you know people think of
Dorian Ace like being very dense
if we could see those two up on stage
together I'm telling you right now Kai
Greene like because of the quads because
of the side of the hamstring the hanging
of the forget it it was just slabs of
beef dude like this guy you've seen him
walk around off season and and every 3x
pants that he's wearing looks like
they're leggings I mean it just it's
amazing and he was able to keep this
condition throughout the entire
bodybuilding season so I I would always
look at him and say well
you're not focusing on one major thing
and that is the peak
and bodybuilding is about the peaking
you can run the 100 meters in the
semifinals and break the world record
but wouldn't you rather do an Olympic
final I'd rather do an Olympic final
it's more significant then and it takes
more discipline it takes more strategy
so that's where I I looked at
bodybuilding it's like everything is a
strategy everything is a process leading
up to two days
that's it all you got to do is be ready
for two days
and that you know I was able to do that
obviously countless times but yeah uh
did he raise my game level up absolutely
and I and I benefit from it
give me your thoughts on Chris Bumstead
most popular
um no rival
really good bodybuilder I saw him when
he was coming up at like what 19 20
years old guys over at Team MuscleTech
used to tell me about him because you
know muscle tech is Canadian company
pretty much and they were saying oh this
guy's coming up and I said yeah
and when and they're like what you don't
think and I go
I'm gonna treat him just like they
treated me meaning I see big things
and he's done those things and like I
shared with him at after his uh Olympia
win
I said now it's just you you solidified
yourself in this category where it's
just you you're running by yourself now
you have no equal
um and what do they do they raise the
weight limit up for everybody else
but now
he has to realize that what I was saying
was true
because they only change the game when
you're dominant
happen the Coleman with the challenge
round happened to me when they decided
to uh make the fans a judge at the
Olympia table they actually put that in
Flex magazine by Jim Mangan himself
so I realized like
they do this to make it more
entertaining needs to remain competitive
and if someone is making it too
uncompetitive right so
yeah they you're telling me that there
wasn't an opportunity to tell Chris
maybe this in January
did you tell all the athletes at the
same time
maybe maybe not right because there's
certain athletes that are going against
them right now that are you know much
bigger in their off season so it makes
you question did they already know or
did someone in their Camp kind of hear
something because everybody in this uh
industry can't hold water so what I
think of Chris bumps that is that he has
a he has a great reach
a great opportunity great following
um great responsibility and an
incredible amount of responsibility
right now why
oh man because look at his demographic
it's not it's like what 30 and under
it's not 30 and over it's 30 and under
probably 25 and under
so your legacy is going to be predicated
how you become a leader for these
younger people
see I can still Inspire these people but
they're gonna maybe reach towards
someone that is around the same age
so that's why there's a responsibility
because he's not perfect he's still
learning he's still young he's very
public yeah about his failings his
insufficiencies his fears dude I I
sat down from with him for two and a
half hours a few months ago in Florida I
genuinely think he might be the most
likable person I've ever met in my life
right he is
so beyond the real deal it's it's insane
and if though if there was somebody to
be this particular micro Generations
Fitness leader people talk about Rogan
the same way especially people that are
friends with them have been friends with
them for a long time and they realize
you they say stuff like you do realize
how rare it is to have a benevolent King
the guy that's at the top of this
particular industry is one who is more
concerned with raising other people up
than raising himself up and is happy to
just spread spoils right all the time
the timing with Chris is impeccable I
think so I think that's what helps too
because I would say
a Jay Cutler with social media back when
he started would be just as popular if
not maybe more um but it's all timing
too and I feel like Chris has done an
incredible job at uh being a champion
being a person of transparency and
vulnerability to allowing people to see
like you said like the the ins and outs
the the flaws the the shortcomings from
the bodybuilding eye
what are you most impressed by with
regards to Chris's physique when he
steps out to do the classic
when he when he decides to do what now
when he does because he's in classic at
the moment right yeah right what what
are you most impressed by when he steps
out on stage
his confidence
um
this past year I felt like it was his
confidence because he knew that
he in order to set yourself apart from
other people you got to know who you are
right so he knew who he was he was like
I got to go out there and give them a
show now now he's looking in the camera
now he's like you know now he's putting
on a performance with his posing even in
prejudging
when you get a chance watch how he walks
out now compared to when he first
started walking now
it starts to realize he is that Jedi not
a master yet but he's a Jedi you know
what I mean
and he's got it he's got the look he's
got the stare now now he's playing with
the crowd and that's a performer
see
a lot of people in the general public
don't realize that we're performers of
art of body art
now he's willing to show it and that's
what's very impressive now I can
actually pay attention before I would
just say oh yeah you know he's
championing this net it's past year I
was like
very nice would you given a a second
life would you have ever enjoyed having
a crack at Classic rather than open
would you have been interested to see
what you could have done had you have
had different kinds of criteria
pillow like this naturally I wouldn't
have been able to do it
like without PDS I wouldn't be I
wouldn't have been able to do classic of
course so
what's the point
I would have I would have uh been at a
disadvantage going against guys that are
enhanced doing classic
but I could tell you I I mean the look
that I had like when I won the New York
pro at 208 and a half that I guess
that's classic
that might have put me in the criteria
because I'm five nine
it wouldn't have been challenging if you
give me the opportunity to go back in
time and say okay it's 2005 Mr USA's you
turn pro as an Open Class bodybuilder
but yet you're still undersized
you're going to compete around 210
but you can have an opportunity to
squeeze down and do classic would you do
it absolutely not
absolutely not because to me
um Mr Olympia is the one that can take
on all Challengers
so the Sandow trophy exemplifies that so
I need the biggest challenge I can have
and knowing that it's a process
it's a process I can still get get these
little wins out to Sean Ray the New York
Pro the Iron Man but these are these are
little wins and I can say that I've
slayed dragons
David versus Goliath type of stuff I
mean think about the guys that I beat in
their Prime
my winner gets a lot of guys that are
different shapes and sizes right classic
would not allow that for me it would
only be him yep understood yeah one of
the things that came up in the
conversation with Chris your sport is
psychologically home only
physically pharmacologically very taxing
and I asked him about any concerns that
he had around longevity
um
were there any points in your career
where you were forced to make a a choice
between well if I keep pushing like this
I'm concerned about what this is going
to do for my health over the long term
and talk me through that you know that
mindset when I love this I love this
conversation because
um
I took less than everybody and I can I
can point it out I have blood work from
the very beginning how deep can you go
into that okay so I'm going to Miss USA
taking 500 milligrams of testosterone
with a shot of Deco week
I didn't have any money
but I whipped everybody's ass first
crack at it and quoted as one of the
greatest Mr Mr USA's of all time
didn't take growth hormone until my
second Arnold Classic how deep are we in
the I turned Pro on o5 we're talking
about 2008. I'd already won two pro
shows and now I decided to take growth
hormone for the first time and you're
still running 500 milligrams of time I
was probably doing like 750. yep very
minimal stuff because Here's my thought
process with this
uh you watch Fast and Furious
you know this good old saying too soon
Junior
that plays in bodybuilding
the guy that hits the nitrous too fast
in the race loses every time why because
that car
was it what little Honda Civic with a
little turbo kit and some
handmade handcrafted Ferraris will
always beat that and if you put a
little bit of a mod on that thing you
can't catch them so you're saying that I
rather would build okay better analogy
foreign
and I can beat you in my base form
that the internet is Happy Dragon Ball Z
so let me let me go ahead and beat you
in the base form let me work on the base
form is that so it seems like then I
can't rely on this stuff because here
with pharmacology and stuff are you
really getting in from a valuable Source
are you getting it from Bayer are you
getting it from sharing are you getting
it from these companies you don't know
you don't work there you really want to
tax your body you really want to take
something that you really don't know
that could really hurt you
and now you're becoming a drug addict
buying drugs from someone at a gym
you're buying it from drug dealers
I know drug dealers I grew up around
drug dealers I know the mentality I
stayed away from that because I was
like you know what like let me just go
ahead and slowly roll myself into this
because if I want to have longevity
after the after my career
it would be nice to show that my blood
work can prove it
would you ever release that my blood
work yeah for money
I'm not just going to offer it up to
somebody but you know that's HIPAA
that's a lot of you know maybe on my own
podcast someday
um okay so I can walk you through what
why okay so I do the Arnold Classic in
2007. I had won the first two pro shows
in 2006 Sean Rave uh and uh New York Pro
realize I need more time off to do the
Olympia I was going to be undersized it
made no sense to get my ass beat by a
bunch of guys that are seasoned veterans
did the 07 Arnold Place fifth first time
ever losing right okay let me take more
time off
decided to have a deeper off season
understand that what are the what is the
difference between me and everybody else
what was just tying time in the gym time
in the gym time in the gym not drugs
what is drugs gonna do it's not going to
shrink time you need time in the gym
okay so it's drugs
so I pound everything and then what you
know my trainer said well I can get you
to Mr Olympia in two three years but we
don't know after what was going to
happen after that so think about that
mentality that we see today everybody's
pounding the stuff and here's the funny
part
the muscle the muscle tissue is damaged
the skin texture is completely off
look man you see
the skin texture
you see that with anybody else probably
not I'm not even running right you
know what I'm saying like how do you
build that you build it with a base form
you know how to come off appropriately
you know how to do so like what Arnold
was saying back in the day we knew how
to do stuff during
it's not an all-year thing because now
you become a drug addict
you know how many drug addicts are in
bodybuilding a tremendous amount
because they're they're chasing
something but they're not winning
something so you got to be a
idiot to go ahead and take all these
drugs right not win put yourself in
not only financial debt
physical debt it seems to a lot of
people especially looking at your era
unbelievable that you wouldn't have just
been taking
everything under the sun but why should
I when I was able to win my first couple
amateur shows clean
and then just add a little bit when I
always heard of a finishing touch that
was what was always talked about and
then I also saw guys in Colorado that
were running a lot not winning
I'm like well okay so you run too much
stuff you know what happens you develop
side effects right
so well if everybody's doing it nah man
why don't you just be different because
maybe I don't want to do this maybe I
don't want to have to take drugs like
this maybe I'm afraid of needles maybe
I'm afraid of what the the side effects
do you ever do you do you own anabolics
2000 book do you own these different
ebooks that tell you the good the bad
the ugly with it I studied all this
so the last thing I ever and you know
what's funny
the real truth
is that what if they started drug
testing severely
severely
I have no base form
I have no base form physically and also
emotionally
take all the drugs away it's like taking
the Instagram away from an influencer
they lose their
what was the maximum that you ever got
to in terms of first test yeah thirteen
hundred I try 15. and then I was like
starting to get watery
and then I remember no I did 15 so I
went I was at 13 then I was like let's
do 15. and then like another dose later
you know like another week goes by and I
was like all right 17 and five or
whatever I think because it was like all
Sustanon and like that
I just got more water it was just stupid
so then the same thing with growth
hormone like Okay so
medical journals will state that if you
take too much of this stuff right like
now you're actually going to inhibit
what more insulin you know problems you
know because I never run insulin never
ran in my entire life never wow
give me some money I'll put on a
freaking show like hand on Bibles like
lie detector test but you're gonna pay
me that million because I'm gonna take
all your damn money
I'm gonna take it all so anybody out
there want a challenge just put the
money up and I'll do it on National
Television I don't give a damn but
you're gonna pay me though because
you're not going to put me through this
and me not get something out of
it so there's that part
but um you know I mess around with Tran
and stuff like that but even that I've
realized how harsh that is that's just
stupid it literally says like liver
kidney damage I was like ah and that's
not happening and you know for me what's
funny for me is that I tried it enough
to realize that I have high prolactin
levels when I take it so oh so you got
high prolactin now you take Dawson X
why am I doing this I'm adding all these
things in why don't I just focus on the
training and the modalities that I'm
talking about like I'm the one that did
the infrared saunas I'm the one that
bought the fattarus 320. I'm the one
that did you know uh neuromuscular
massage I'm the one that's doing you
know DRX 9000 you know with the
decompression of the spine and stuff
like that while taking acupuncture while
doing stem while doing oxygen all at the
same time living in Denver Colorado I'm
that dude
you can't name another athlete
all you see is cold plunges
and dry needling
and scraping which is stupid as hell
because you see how they scrape into
these scraping people doing the grass
and whether the the the their blood
blisters and stuff that's not gonna
yield any growth that's just being dumb
so look
you know my drug use was very minimal
because I understood that there was life
afterwards I had some favorite you know
PDS and stuff like that like you know
like winning stuff like that and growth
but I mean I just made sure that I took
enough to get the job done because again
if they were ever going to start testing
for I needed to be ready to be like
I don't need this I have a foundation I
got a foundation and you look at me now
people say oh man you look younger you
look this guess what because I treated
my body right
you got these other guys and I also
didn't have social media
here's the thing when you don't have
magazines
you got social media
a professional bodybuilder right now is
actually
um having to decide if they're an
influencer or a bodybuilder
you see what I'm saying the influencer
can get on some cycles and stuff almost
look like a pro which they try to do
they take all the best angles in the
lighting and also some photoshop their
they sell courses they sell
products and stuff
and they do it for a short period of
time right but they can create like a
thousand episodes within six months
and then they can kind of just not do
events because you see some you don't
see a lot of events with the mat because
and they can just dress normally because
they're not a pro or whatever right Pro
bodybuilders now feel like they have to
compete with them
and the same and they share the same
sponsors
so unfortunately the owners of these
companies just focus on certain levels
of Engagement now for a bigger person
that weighs over 240 to 270 to 200 now
how many 300 pound bodybuilders do we
have compared to Ronnie's era a ton more
and they don't outmass Ronnie with
quality muscle why
because they're taking drugs more than
they're actually doing the work they're
not allowing
the body to catch up
so you think that one of the problems
with the current generation is an
over-reliance on YouTube bro you see it
on Tick Tock you see it on YouTube what
are we talking about most of the mostly
on 90 or not
I'm sorry Natty or not that's like this
thing right that's right the meme at the
moment and none of them are
show me what you look like in high
school show me that you have the the
actual
Integrity that you can do this for a
long period of time majority of these
people are showing the their
sensationalizing drugs use
they're no different than a drug addict
we'll get back to talking to Phil in one
minute but first I need to tell you
about gymshark gymshark make my favorite
training kit in fact I'm all I'm wearing
right now is gymshark and these
Studio shorts these training shots for
men are the greatest men's training
shorts I've ever found and I've tried
pretty much everything I love the fit I
love the color of all of the stuff that
gymshark make and these Studio shorts
for men have lasted me way too long I
got these over a year ago and they still
look fantastic they've even started
branching out into Graphics tees now
this old school one plus the T-shirt you
might have seen me wearing in the Chris
Bumstead Vlog are just so cool they have
free returns for 30 days so that no
matter where on the planet you buy it
with their international shipping you
can buy it risk-free also they just
updated my super secret product page
with everything that I use and recommend
for men and women check out all of those
pieces at bit.ly shark wisdom and use
the code mw10 at checkout to get a 10
discount site-wide and worldwide with no
minimum order size that's bit.ly shock
wisdom and mw10 a checkout you mentioned
that Trend and this is something that
Chris brought up and I thought it was
really really telling that both of you
guys have said this it was something
that he tried uh he's got autoimmune
disorders yeah so he definitely can't be
doing that no and he he was like it's
just way too toxic
um but he conceded that it got him to a
place during some particular competition
that he would struggle to get back to
now he's got my size and he's got blah
blah blah but there were certain
elements that it facilitated in his in
his performance oh like as far as like a
physical hardness conditioning and stuff
like that I could understand I could
understand but for you you said that
insulin is something that you you didn't
want to ever touch uh Trend would be
something else was there anything else
that was completely off the table for
you or why with them or anything else as
well well I felt like Trend usage
um first of all again we're not in the
old school era where you're getting like
real Parable in and stuff so you don't
really know
so
and then look at the color of it
looks pretty gnarly man when you're
injecting what's the color of it it
looks like orange
like you really want to put something
that toxic in your body like I don't
know man and then people talk about like
okay well it has to have a filtration
rate of session says with benzoyl
alcohol and therefore you're going to
have the trend cough and blah blah blah
man why am I even wanting to go through
this how many times did I sit there
coughing my lungs out because of this
damn drug it's like is this really
necessary can I just do something else
and why no insulin why do I need it I'm
already winning
I'm already winning why do people do it
let me ask you why do you think people
do it
because they want to be bigger and
leaner it makes people leaner
the thing I think they suffer from the
fact that um they want roundness they
want fullness in the muscles because
it's the most anabolic property in the
body right so they figure like oh if I
take this I look bigger and you know
I think I have some of the most
well-rounded muscle we've ever seen
why do I need more I just need more
separation I need moisturization I need
more I mean and that's what I need but
like for instance let's say that it was
more dryness that you were going for it
was more separation in the muscles that
you were going for that could have
encouraged you to run a ton of
something else a ton of growth
hormone a ton of Windsor a ton
of something if you do that you're only
going to get now all right so you could
use Winstrol for instance you're going
to do that and now you got you know
water-based drugs mixed in with
oil-based drugs you're gonna have
pockets bro like is
you're gonna run out of spaces here if
you notice that my shoulders like even
recently they are more striated than
majority of people that compete why is
that because they doing all these
they're pinning all this other in
there oh so there's just sight
inflammation of course
and the judges don't even know any
better right now they just look at it
like well it looks round and it's not
they don't how do they know they're
going from Old School like how it's
supposed to look and so I suppose who
has to write at shoulders
damn right
damn they only got this part they don't
even have shredded rear delts
only for the day of the show now some of
them do don't get me wrong like some of
them do
but you know you start seeing all this
you know
I mean you give you give your dog
insulin enough they're going to develop
Scar Tissue you know what I'm saying so
like
these guys have to be very worried in my
opinion that with all the abundance of
these new drugs that are available and
peptides and stuff like that you got to
be very careful and you have to ask a
question how much blood work is being
talked about these guys aren't talking
about they'll talk about a little bit oh
yeah my doctor said no they didn't what
doctor you really dealing with have you
done a Boston Health Scan I have you
know what I'm saying do you actually
know what parasites you have I have I've
done a GI map and stuff like that this
is what we're talking about if you were
able to even do a certain amount of
breath work you would actually get more
oxygen into the body which would make
you bigger you know did your holistic
more holistic approach to this stuff I
think would surprise an awful lot of
people an awful lot of people yeah
because they assume I just took a bunch
of drugs and this and that you know eat
because that's simple
because everybody could do that it's
like nah man in order to get uh seven Mr
Olympia's amongst these guys you got to
do something they ain't doing and what
they're thinking you're doing is drug
related I'm thinking well nah man like
for three months after the Olympia I go
vegan right or something like that I'm
just gonna try it
I'm just gonna try it
I'm gonna come off on all supplements
people say oh it feels not that big in
the off season this and that it's like
yeah man I'm letting my body heal
the war is over for now Chris does the
same Chris has it obviously he doesn't
need to hold quite as much I also
learned from the from guys like myself
and Jay and other people probably too of
realizing like you want to do this for a
long time you got to treat your body
right
and he's being smart with the modalities
that he has and the money that he's you
know earned you know getting the stem
cells and doing this other stuff I mean
it's smart I didn't have that you
know that was one thing I mean I thought
I had that but you know
I was always looking and I still do to
this day I think
um what we're seeing again you know like
drug addiction
how much you taken
um and then I have to ask him like
man you look like that and that's what
you're taking
that means you need more time in the gym
just training and dieting short
gratification short term man what do you
think it's not it's not good what do you
think the most sort of egregious use is
at the moment what would you guess I
hear a lot of kids talk about Trend like
non-stop that's all I hear right now I'm
like why would you want to talk about
The Most Dangerous Drug around
I mean I get it like you want to run a
little bit of testosterone or something
like that but man these are also kids
your natural testosterone is already
through the roof
and the problem is Imagine That imagine
that all right so you got kids that are
18 even 17 on up to the mid to late 20s
buying God knows what bathtubs drugs or
with you know they're getting the Old
Mexico stuff or the uh Pharaoh Perros
and Gatos on them you know what I mean
yeah
put a little rabbit on there or
something I don't know kangaroo
bro like you know how dumb you sound you
sound like a clown
ain't gonna be funny when you're in your
40s
if you make it
you know what I'm saying I've had some
you know right prominent deaths yeah or
people that couldn't continue to compete
because these things
and I refuse to you know co-sign this
I'm even the guy that realizes that
diuretic use is a big deal
so because man that's hard but that's
that's blood pressure meds man like what
are you doing so you're trying to get
you know more water out right
if you abuse that you know what can
happen to you right I mean you can die
right is that something that you were
very conscious of uh yeah because I know
how to read
what does this do do I really need it
why do I still have water on my body
because you have more fat on your body
Phil
why don't you just do more cardio man
why don't you just over cardio yourself
over train yourself so you don't have to
do that you know why my muscles popped
and would round and this and that and
the other it's not because the
insulin people thought like
oh you dummies I train a certain way
I wasn't trying to Max
on bench and squat and this now is going
for more volume
using what I have
okay I just needed more density over
time
I already had the roundness when I was
playing basketball in high school and
college I already have this here's what
I already got
I'm not afraid to diet oh you need to
get the water out oh man this this prep
hurts you know I can't drink any water
all right well you know I only had two
water breaks in in a college practice
you know I'm saying like at the
beginning and in the middle
right when you walk in you may take a
sip of water you take some while you're
shooting free throws after you ran we
used to run this do this uh workout
called three sixteens so before that you
know you do all your drills
and then you have like a mini game five
on five mini game 20 minutes running
clock
going over you know game plan this and
that and the other but you're going hard
right
but it's 20 minutes running clock so you
gotta you gotta go hard game game speed
playing 20 minutes running clock game
speed is hard
and then after that you got to run 316
so 316s at sideline to sideline 16 times
in the end in the ends 16 touches in one
minute with one minute rest and then you
do it again one minute
one minute and then at three sixteens
in six minutes
and then you go through free throws and
if you don't make over 70 you got to get
online
online on a line you got to run more now
you just go down and you know not side
to side right
I know what it feels like to be parched
you know what I'm saying so like when it
was time to cut water I'm like it sucks
but the only thing that sucked was
having to eat while being parched you
know being thirsty oh interesting but I
didn't have all that like oh you know
I can't think I can't this I'm like I've
already been prepped for this now I'm
already having more confidence knowing
everyone else is suffering everyone else
is suffering I'm suffering
but I know what it is
talk to me you've alluded that to
um
differences or uniqueness in your
training style uh what was it that you
or what were the principles that you
attribute your success to from a
training standpoint
ah knowing who I am it all goes back to
knowing who you are I'm not a I'm not a
guy that was bench pressing 500 pounds
in college you know what I'm saying like
I wasn't that dude I was strong but I
wasn't one of those guys like you get
like so you got to know who you are like
for me
um never bench press over for uh oh five
plays I did five plays before and that
was a lot like what's that 4.95 so like
all right so let's just say 500 pounds
you know
I think that's good enough for one rep
max
there's guys that can rep that out but
I'm like but I beat them
so it's not necessary
um what's the degree of difficulty to
where you know where's the point of no
return meaning
I'm getting diminishing returns
potentially getting injured on a back
Squad you know leg press I had to know
what those numbers were
but as you get stronger uh-huh you're
70 80 percent 85 percent one RM yeah for
you know like hypertrophy range reps
that still continues to go up yeah right
because you are getting stronger over
time so presumably like you're still
having to ramp that up yeah but I also
Train by myself so you want to go put
700 pounds on your back by yourself
be my guest or you could put three plays
or four places and rep it out 20 times
my leg workout let's say for 2012 and
2013 Olympia
um five sets 20 rep 30 315 squats with
two minutes resting periods take that
from the top again so you do leg
extensions for pre-exhaustion yep just
do like three working sets for 20 or
whatever you want to do then you go into
back squash you know you warm up with
the 135 to 225 and then you throw three
plates on 315 on you know three on the
side you do that 20 reps
take two minutes and do it again
and do that for five reps five rounds
five rounds of that sorry yeah five sets
of that and you probably only a 12
minute workout and then you keep going
now you're still doing your vertical leg
press your angle leg press your walking
lunges
now we go in the hamstrings okay so how
you doing the calves and now you're
gonna do that three days later
and you're doing that while you're still
doing cardio for the Olympia on a step
mill you're still doing that squeezing
your glutes every repetition not
actually leaning over the
equipment like everybody else because
they're a you're actually standing
up straight and if you are holding it
it's just something you don't fall and
you're stepping and you're squeezing and
you're building your legs while you're
doing it and you're doing it for 40 to
45 minutes once if not twice a day
that's how I got the striatic glutes
that's why you saw all the cores running
down my hamstrings that no one else has
you know what I'm saying so
I I I made it difficult for a reason
because I knew if I could train by
myself doing that
I'm gonna be better than everybody else
but mind you yeah you know when I if I
did have a spot I still wouldn't say hey
man let's go do
you know five play six plates you know
I've done that and it's like
let's if I'm gonna go more than fourth
place on the back squat and I feel
really strong instead of putting another
fifth one how about I just do front
squats with four plates
let's just do that change the angular
yeah just change the angle up because
now we're running into a point where
my body is going to be conditioned to
lift all this crazy ass weight and I may
not be getting the muscular activation
that is necessary to proliferate the
growth and the separation that I need so
then I can compete because you can see
how the muscles grow like you know if
you set if not that I did but I had the
Mind muscle connection I know when
things are firing I have enough low
levels of body fat to see things moving
if I don't see the things moving I got a
few things to register data maybe
there's a compression in the disc so
let's make sure that I'm getting the
Chiropractic the acupuncture and the
decompression going right because if
something's compressed it's hitting the
nerve and I'm not getting the fire comp
power so you know I'm always paying
attention to all these things it seems
to me that you're talking about volume
here in a way that I think a lot of
people wouldn't no wouldn't typically
have thought of you know anything over
14 is cardio is a meme but
I never heard that so that's what they
say anything of 14 is called he's like a
bromine so these Bros have never won a
Sandow and that's the problem so
they're doing this because they are
young and they haven't tried anything
long enough they're expecting such a
vast amount of
of a muscle or weight gain and then
they're like well no you need to do it
this way it's like keep doing it that
way and let's see what you look like but
first of all let's analyze your goal
what is the goal you want to aesthetic
goal to compete and be somebody let's
see what you work out at let's see how
this works let's really quantify these
things so you're playing with reps
rest and intensity yeah I want intensity
here I want to make sure that I can do
it right uh am I the one saying like oh
yeah you know 25 pound dumbbells is
going to build you 23 inch arms now what
I'm saying is is that uh you need to
definitely produce enough uh strength to
grow those big muscles but at some given
point in time
is it is it necessary to curl a hundred
pound dumbbell to get those arms no I
proved it I also proved to grow a back
if you see my back from you know from
the amateur ranks through the first
years as a pro to the end
one of the best backs ever right I did
that with no deadlift show me a video of
me doing deadlifts why because I wanted
to prove that I could do it without it
why not what were you doing instead of
deadlift what was your issue
ah because you know
when I was getting ready for the usas
back in 2005 I you know I kind of had an
accident I was doing like 625
conventional not Sumo conventional and I
felt something in my neck and I was like
that's stupid
so sometimes you're gonna tap on the
shoulder by an Angel that's saying hey I
covered your ass this time next time
that pop may be something so I was like
all right
uh this is me talking to honey Rambo my
channel honey what do you think I should
be doing he's like I If you're going to
do deadlifts just do them with dumbbells
or like do it like a rack pool or
something like that so have I done rack
pulls yeah
um
yeah because rack pools you know what I
can do as I'm coming up I can rotate
right here and I'm now squeezing if you
just take if you keep your chest up
right here and you know you're like at
that 90 degrees and you kind of pull
back you feel it in your lats yep that's
all I have to replicate
for me to have to go all the way down
and do for what I get it like I'm not
saying that people can't
do it that way I'm saying for me
this way worked so from 2005
you basically didn't deadlift for the
rest of your money no very I mean from
that point in time
especially during a prep
like I said if it was not in one of my
like DVDs it probably never happened
okay yeah
let's say that for the rest of time yeah
you only had 10 exercises to hold on to
and grow as much muscle as you could
what would you choose and why incline uh
incline presses no question about it
dumbbell uh dumbbell more likely because
you know it's just you can do a lot with
the dumbbells over the barbell right
um I always want that shelf up here it
looks great in t-shirts and uh yeah you
know if you're hitting a side shot you
want the upper PEC development to exist
it is something about the angle that's
so comfortable as well yeah it feels so
not it feels right yeah it feels right
yeah you don't feel as much in danger
in my opinion yeah even when you're
doing flies you know like you can
just it just feels so good you know so
that would be one of them
cilaterals for sure
dumbbell lateral raise standing seated
standing for sure and where do you what
were your cues on I knew you're going to
say this yeah from the side to the side
are you out in front a little bit what
are you thinking to the side yep to the
side are you leading with elbows leading
with arms uh more just well I guess that
would just be with arms right yeah so
because sometimes you see people almost
flaring up with dumbbells down as you
did that your traps moved yep so I don't
need that yeah I don't want that lower
trap now that's gonna uh I just need to
get it if I'm working this I understand
it's a secondary muscle but I don't need
to be you're isolating because you end
up doing this you see guys like they
come down and they're doing this you see
it
why is that moving can I deactivate it
sure
right here okay cool let's do that so
okay
oh
one armed preachers
one on preacher curls dumbbells again it
could be on a machine or dumbbells you
know but but since we're gonna you know
only have some dumbbells on a deserted
island we're gonna do that but you can
use whatever you want yeah so you got
the best gym in in history definitely a
preacher curl okay um and why single
because I can concentrate more on one
arm than two I can also isolate and
understand
why is one's arm stronger than the other
and am I performing the rep the same on
either arm now if I'm in a fixed
position I can't tell so I need to see
I need to feel and I need to physically
see this
so are you supinating on that are you
gonna oh yeah I'm gonna do that but I
also got to recognize like am I having
any uh you know bicep tendon stuff and
like that and uh which I actually
have right now I'm like damn like okay
yeah yeah yeah you know that's three so
that's three uh hack squats for sure
for sure
oh my gosh it just feels incredibly
strong to be in that position I love it
it's
yeah I I did a lot of damage on that
machine
um what are your cues when doing hack
squat
well you know the platform
I can go wide I can go at the top I can
go at the bottom I can go narrow you
know I like to go a little bit you can
have that that can be all part of four
yeah exactly see but it's all you're
saying yeah so you're playing the system
okay so that's full okay
this is fun
um
rear delts uh but but uh
face pulls with the uh with the with the
Rope okay I love that yeah at a
roundabout eye height yeah uh yeah right
right here yep
um you know since we're using that rope
you know tricep extensions
overhead
damn okay yeah
so that's what six foot six okay
four more
You Gotta Throw Another chest movement
in there so
um I mean we did the incline dumbbell
press we gotta have an incline dumbbell
fly
um why put both of those in what are you
getting out of the fly that you're not
getting out getting a good stretch and
I'm able to contract you know
differently as well working that same
plane
um
three adults what about back we got to
throw some back in there so underhand
barbell uh uh Rose underhand bent over
bent over Rose underhand yep
um what's your reason for going
underhand rather than over Hunter um
because I've noticed that overhand I'm
getting more of I'm initially you're
going to fill it more in your forearms
right here yep and I'm only going to get
so much and I feel like it's more like
I'm gonna there's more margin for error
I believe whereas if you're coming here
I don't feel it as much and it's
simulating what I would do on stage
pulling the elbows back so would you do
uh
I guess a part of that as well is
restricting the uh
injury risk from being bent over so much
like underhand you're always going to be
a little weaker so would you do that
from a rack rather than from the floor
oh I've done that from before right yeah
I've done that from before A lot of
axial loads being at that angle yeah in
your lower back but it's much less than
a deadlift I suppose yeah but then
sometimes you can go to like a squat
rack and then it'll have like the little
bars there so you can put so you get
safety bars so you just pull it off of
that cool okay I think you've got two
left so I got two left oh boy
what have we got let's recap so we've
got the incline you got incline dumbbell
incline fly lateral we have lateral
raises you have hack squats yep
single arm uh preacher push Downs
Facebook face pulls and then and over
underhand you know what I'm going to go
with Pull-Ups
neutral underhand overhand overhand
overhand wide
and I guess last one would be another
legs
step mill
you can use the step Mills the 10th
exercise
and did you I can carve out the legs I
can
you know I can I can do glutes with that
did you ever do that weighted
yeah actually I did I wore a wheat vest
for what show was that it was early in
my career we were like weight vest and I
wear like ankle weights and I did
something that no one else ever did
I was using
um e-stem units while I was doing cardio
like a compex yeah I used compacts
because I was sponsored by that for a
while so I was doing compacts on
stepmail did anyone that thinks that uh
electric stem training is not like put a
an sp6 or an sp8 on you and turn it up
to 25 and try and do a squat an air
squat yeah and tell me that it's Agony
that that would uh
the only thing I I think now
is
like you know the neuroplasticity and
like also like neural feedback you get
by using one of those machines I don't I
would love to be able to test that
because I think with it doing the work
kind of for you you may lose some of
that
so you have to be careful I think with
um overloading it yes because you can
push it further you're going to push it
further than you can really do it so I
know I did that but I'm an extreme
athlete you know with that when it comes
to the stepper very very popular cardio
exercise for bodybuilders what are
people missing what are they getting
wrong when you see it they're holding on
to the they're holding they're hugging
the damn thing
you know what they're also doing by
doing that they're rounding out their
back and you think about doing this
you're I mean just me doing this right
now like that doesn't seem comfortable
why not just stand straight
let me just slow it down maybe you know
what I'm saying maybe not have it at
five or six because I gotta
and you hear that person stomping on the
damn things if they weighed 250 pounds
or something like that you know their
knees would be shot
their knees would be toast so you're
using control even though you should you
should
you should you should you should have it
at level one level two and slowly do it
now it now the reason why you won't do
that ladies and gentlemen is because
it's boring
but think about how much muscle
activation you can have on that with
your glutes and quads with each step
actually being Purpose Driven so my
whole mentality when I would do cardio
and I'm giving y'all all the damn
Secrets man
put it like this you got to gamify your
cardio as much as possible so if you
could have every step count towards
something you could actually sculpt
glutes
quads
and isn't that the whole point of doing
cardio or you just want to sweat
you just want to sweat and burn calories
what's the difference between just
sweating and count I'm building
muscle
wouldn't it be great if you could do
cardio and build muscle at the same time
yeah but it feel like I gotta slow it
down and I gotta squeeze yeah you're
being more intentional just like if you
were doing eccentric movements I'm being
more intentional
this is bodybuilding man
that's bodybuilding it's not always
going to be as fast as you want it to be
it's not about you anyway it's about
your muscles it's about using these
machines to make them get the maximum
benefit while reducing the most amount
of physical strain on your ligaments and
Joints it seems like getting your ego
out of the way is a big how they gonna
do it when they got a rooting session
for them at the gym they got to be by
themselves
and a lot of people can't have that
option so granted like I had keys to a
gym and all this other stuff but you
know I was raised as an only child so I
I knew who I was long time ago yeah so
you get it that's why we get along man
I'm like yeah you know I was interested
in this
um
the
we can call it the only child effect I
think I think every every only child
that I know there's not actually that
many yeah um
has a degree of introspection
some of them yeah more frequently have a
degree of Interest introspection that is
rare I think not always adaptive or
useful or enjoyable and even in me like
yeah sometimes especially when I was in
my teens and 20s I kind of wish that I
could have switched it off
um but now
it's one of the things that I'm I enjoy
the most I enjoy my degree of
introspection I enjoy the conversations
I have with myself yeah
um what
have you reflected on about how being an
only child impacted your
mindset your approach to
all of the things that you've done
across your career
I'm My Own first responder
No One's Gonna Save you Phil
you have to be your first your own
responder you want something in life you
have to want it more than anybody else
and you have to assume that there's no
one else to help you
so what are you going to do about it
you're gonna wait for your your cousin
or your big brother you know what I'm
saying like like yeah they have no big
brothers or sisters right so that means
you gotta fight your own battles that
means you have to be more calculated
can't be like the other jackasses you
know walking home from school picking a
fight with you because they got bigger
yeah because they got the bigger brother
that'll beat your ass if you decide to
beat him up right so you got to be smart
right you gotta be like all right uh am
I but maybe I am willing to do that that
one day right because I'm calculated on
how I'm gonna do it
um
you got to know
self-love you got to understand the
words that you tell yourself mean
something
because if there's no one pouring into
like a big brother or sister that tells
you like oh Janelle didn't like you
because of this or this is how you talk
to her next time or you know or John
John you know just doesn't get it and
you know this is what has a regulation
outside you need to really have your own
data
and then ask yourself questions
at a very early age right emotional
regulation
um and I would say for me it was it was
great that I grew up in the 80s where
you know I was a huge martial artist fan
and I love Bruce Lee so I started you
know taking martial arts and competing
in competition so it was about you and
focus so when I would be by myself I'm
like
yeah be like water I can but empty out
my cup and understand that there's
things I should learn
and play life with your eyes
he's doing something stupid I don't need
to be doing that
let me pull myself out of bad situations
let me give you a uh um
model that I absolutely love it's the
reverse role model so I grew up in a
very working class area of the northeast
of the UK uh famous for only having the
highest teen pregnancy rating in the UK
which it then lost so it didn't even
have that anymore after a little while
um and there were some people that had
certain characteristics like the sort of
person I wanted to be like
but there were far more people who were
like the person I didn't want to be like
yes so I came up with this idea of a
reverse role model which is I could look
around the Cricket Club that I played at
or the school that I went to or wherever
I was and say okay I really don't want
his relationship with his wife and I
really don't want the way that he treats
money and I really don't want his
gambling addiction I don't want the way
that he speaks to his friends so good
man yeah I really think that
much of success in life
involves avoiding pitfalls more than
Expediting successes yeah there's a rule
for mathematics called Never multiply by
zero and it means that if you take one
million multiplied by three thousand
multiplied by two multiplied by 444
multiplied by zero you get zero right
you never multiply by zero and an
example here might be
you spend all of this time eating
organic you avoid seed oils you make
sure that your blood work's done but one
day you decide to drive your car without
a seat belt
all of that good work 444 000 times 1
million times multiplied by zero you
spend all of your teams being
responsible you go to college you get
the degree you start to build up a a
really great life and you're just about
to go and start traveling the world and
you decide to have unprotected sex with
somebody and someone gets pregnant and
it's an accidental pregnancy
it's not quite zero but your life is now
taken in an unbelievably different path
all right choices and consequences yeah
absolutely I agree with you yeah so I I
think
trying to find examples of people like
the person you don't want to be like is
may be more valuable than having Role
Models like the person you do want to be
like around 100 I mean like I said
earlier play life with your eyes
observe
and then ask yourself does that you want
to be like that
because you're hanging around them
um it was interesting uh my booking
agent Thomas we were in the uh Uber
heading over here
and a gentleman that was driving
happened to
be in the same neighborhood as me
growing up
very crazy
and um
we were basically talking about he was
actually he was sharing uh about a
person that we knew
they got shot and killed out here
years ago you know playing the NFL this
not you know so anyway and I was like
man
over a traffic stop
one decision
of getting out of the car being this big
ass dude charged the cop now were they
supposed to shoot him hell no but
emotional regulation
that one decision
he paid the ultimate cost
so
where I grew up
very synonymous like style like what
you're talking about we used to call
people stumble bums stumble bum like
you're gonna be a bum one day because
you stumbling over you know you stumble
bum
I saw drug dealers I saw a lot of drug
use I saw teen pregnancy
um my first my first High School dance
ended up in a friend's brother getting
shot in the face six times about 10
yards away from me
so I had to understand like you start
hanging around certain types of people
bro like you're gonna be around more
so now you got to realize also
this is why your parents would always
try to over be overprotective and tell
you what to do and all right so you
can't always be defiant
but then you have to play life with your
eyes and know that there's a certain
time that you should probably head home
that kid don't have curfew because maybe
his parents just don't care maybe his
parents aren't there
but yours are so you need to make better
decisions because your choices will
always yield either positive or negative
consequences better put them condoms on
boy because you just might get a kid out
of it is that what you want no then
either don't have sex or be protected
right in my high school so damn ghetto I
mean I hate to say it this but like or
they were it was ghetto there but it was
smart we had a Teen Health Center inside
the high school you can go get condoms
you can go get checked for STDs all this
stuff because it practices and you know
scds and stuff sort of trying to be
preventative knowing that kids are not
gonna aren't gonna listen
um
in fact it's just funny like when I
graduated college I remember my stepdad
you know no my mom was like you made it
you made it you made it I was like yeah
I made it like and I'm like pop like
made it out
well pop said well you didn't get a girl
pregnant he made it he didn't get a
girlfriend forget about the diploma yeah
yeah forget about the degree and all
that yeah you did all that without
you know causing any trouble but you
know what we're talking about too Chris
is that we built social equity
throughout all the decisions
all of them knows that we told friends
or family or or even that crazy bastard
on our arms saying go do this go do this
you know we said no because we were
driven by our Legacy we're driven by
something that we dreamed about and we
knew that
getting behind the wheel of a car while
you inebriated is just too much of a
price I I refuse to do that because
man do I really want to be in the paper
for that do I really want to kill
somebody or myself or one of my friends
do I really want to you know this is
crazy but I mean it's just like you know
you playing life with your eyes I
remember when uh Len Bias died famous
basketball player he was drafted by the
Boston Celtics this guy was going to be
better than Jordan okay like just
imagine this like you know you have like
a big three well the Celsius already had
that and they were going to add in let's
say like a LeBron James he was basically
like built like a LeBron James buff
could shoot rebound everything you
should look him up he did he did cocaine
the first time on draft night died
died
done didn't even get to see
his first game as a pro right
a champion That Never Was
you gotta think as he's probably
Odin
oh
zero
zero this is what I get
and this is where we have to acknowledge
the
different demons that people have and
understand like but I just want to feel
something you know I just want to blend
in with some of my friends I just you
know I just want to have man I just have
a little bit a little taste he had a
little taste
it's done
so seeing that
I cried I remember telling my mom I was
like she was like what's wrong baby I
was like he died you know he died he
died
and that was an opportunity for her to
say this is why you'll never do that you
know what I'm saying yeah so
you know I've I've always tried to be
mindful
of that that angel that's inside of us
all that says hey don't do that don't
touch that hot stove you're gonna get
burnt
um
you know you're going to learn a couple
lessons in life and those lessons are
always paid with a price that's
expensive or inexpensive inexpensive
parking ticket expensive then bias
you got to figure this out and you got
to be
you can be so egotistical
that you think that you'll cheat death
or cheat the system or whatever so it's
the ones that actually
do all the things the right way
throughout their entire life that have
built a real Legacy you know and and
it's something admirable admirable am
admirable sorry here's the thing as well
man like imagine that you do manage to
make
a number of bad decisions and stack the
deck against your favor and somehow you
do make it through the only way that
you've done that is by putting a
blindfold on and running through a
Minefield and simply by chance
I would rather try and this is my risk
aversion right I I in business in
everything that I do I'm very very
risk-averse uh which means that I
sometimes don't take opportunities when
they come but it also means that I
usually tend to avoid pitfalls as best I
can uh
if you do do the wrap the blindfold
untie it and run the only way that you
make it through unscarred
is by sheer chance
that's it
sure chance you know um
if you're faith-based I mean you could
throw that in there for sure
um
but yeah you may not want to try that
too many times and and what you're
speaking of in my opinion is a level of
discernment
so
understanding there's ideation stage and
then you have to figure out strategy
and you have to figure out those
pitfalls right
and then make it relatable to you like
would you play Mario Brothers knowing
that there's like a place where you
could jump and if you miss you die
well well there's price in your life
that hey man
you're gonna jump you better calculate
it and there's some people who will take
that jump every single time and you're
like dude there's no respawns yeah
there's no respawns in this life so you
got to be very mindful of this you
got to be very mindful of
um hey I'm gonna try this drug or I'm
gonna do this be mindful man because
there's some people that have had some
really bad you know data that doesn't
support your decisions do you you really
want to do that and if and if you do hey
and you make it
there's still data that says if you try
it again you may you know it's like
Russian Roulette you know like
eventually you know you're gonna lose so
what are you willing to lose what do you
want in the game how do you leverage
these things
and hey it's your life you make it make
sense for you
but yeah I know like with business and
stuff you really you only learn is
when you lose you know
um it's a great teacher
um some of the greatest entrepreneurs
are the ones that lost eight if not nine
figures in their 30s to then be a
billionaire in their 50s
but nowadays I look at this I'm like
where can I actually learn from as many
people as possible that have that have
all that have made mistakes you know
like sometimes I always look at like
pastors
they're not perfect a lot of the good
ones had bad past you know like oh I was
this I was this I think it's talk from
Real World experience you know
so I just try to align myself with
people that have endured some type of
level of adversity but understood
the patterns the the strategies the
enough is enough mentality like enough
is enough
I screwed around when I was in high
school in college I screwed around man
like it's time to grow up and and
harness that energy within and and and
push it and just keep going knowing that
there's going to be pitfalls there's
going to be I mean it
but you're gonna get some
you're gonna get hit man I think a lot
of people just don't want to get hit and
that's what goes back to the pain
tolerances and stuff and you you got to
know you're going to get your ass beat
depending on what you want if you want
just the typical five grand a month job
I mean yeah you may have you know some
things I want to make 50 Grand a month
come with a different level you want to
be 5 million a month there's some people
that listen they'll say I don't want to
be that CEO I'm good being the CEO or
even just c-level you know person
because I can still see my kids they can
have a great life with me they value
things different they know that if they
put too much emphasis on just this title
of running a Fortune 500 company
someone may get left behind and then
they may not understand whether it be my
wife or my kids or my friends you know I
had to think about that in my career
like
you know with friends they're not gonna
understand so you can't hang out with
them a lot of my 30s I didn't see my
college friends
but it's all good because I got got what
I wanted out of it it's kind of like
Kobe Bryant like he didn't hang out with
people he didn't do those things you
know on draft night he gets drafted he
goes to the gym
you know that that's I think that's uh
how you
that's how you answer your call to
Greatness you do it and you don't stop
you do not stop because uh
oh man it would be really shitty at the
end of that life of yours that you were
able to look at the the version of self
that you should have been and that
person kind of puts their arm around you
and says
Phil man you could have did all this let
me tell you about it
and I and you
this is supposed to be the promised land
but before we walk there
I just got to show you what he could
have done now you did okay
I want to hurt you but this is who I am
and you just be in tears
so upset that all those y's in the road
all those decisions that could have been
made
with some sacrifice with some
discernment with some humility
was with the ability to just say enough
is enough with his BS and I just need to
have some stamina
that you could really achieve who you're
truly supposed to be not just for
yourself but for others because that's
really what I believe in like afterlife
is that I would see that person and he
would be able to say look at the people
who you impacted based on what you did
and
you know I I uh
if when I have moments where I am
fatigued
I think of that
and I focus on that and that's when
it is just get your ass up you
know like you gotta say whatever it is
because that future version of self is
someone that is really the gift
and if you really think that
imagine the people
when they walk past your grave
that's very
I met him at the the Expo
and here we had a whole line of people
and he poured into me man and son
that's the role model I want you to be
he helped me
I I won't stop until I
you know
in my opinion can lay lay down and say
you know what
I know I help people not because I held
a phone on my hand and stuff like that
but I know because those people were
right about you
see we have followers and stuff but you
know if you Google yourself you probably
have less search results because no one
wrote about you
I looked you up people write about you
because you do things like this
you produce intellectual conversation
well I truly appreciate
and um
you know I wish you all the best because
this is dope but uh you know you got me
thinking
um
men in general
have to dream again
have to start declaring what they really
want and they can't just be a watch or a
car man
it has to be something of True Legacy
that if none of this really no Jewels
mattered What jewels are you leaving
behind that are in the mind that can
imprint on someone's soul
Phil Heath ladies and gentlemen Phil I
absolutely adore your energy I I I've
really really enjoyed today
where should people go if they want to
keep up to date with all of the things
that you're doing at the moment ah just
at Phil Heath at Phil Heath and I'm
redoing my website because I got a lot
of cool things coming up but I have an
upcoming documentary that will be
announced at some point in time
hopefully this year called breaking
Olympia it actually has won um Film
Festival Awards in the Florence Film
Festival Awards uh for uh uh best
documentary and Best Director
um it's been co-produced by seven bucks
Productions I think you guys know who
that is uh with Danny Garcia and Dwayne
The Rock Johnson so be on the lookout
either for that at the end of this year
or the beginning of next year
um it's being picked up by a Hollywood
studio which is the first of its kind
even Pumping Iron didn't have that so I
wish I could tell you who it is but
people liked it put it like this when
it's the Hollywood studio it always
starts
with their name at the beginning and uh
you know of course I'm um you know
working with transcend you know great
HRT company you know we produce a lot of
medications for people but more
importantly we work with uh veterans
which I truly appreciate their their um
you know the commitment along with First
Responders so we just you know I said on
the board for the foundation so I help
raise money for those uh people in need
especially at the top that have been
knocked out of the fight that have PTSD
TBI those things
um so you can follow me obviously on my
social media you can click the link in
the bio and you can see all the cool
stuff that I'm doing you know shout out
to flexpro meals all those guys Chic uh
gymshark of course because that's why
I'm here and I'm really excited to
proliferate more badassery with this
company because I watched them from the
very beginning being at the freaking
body power at the NEC you know what I
mean and seeing their stamina and their
willingness to Champion through uh not
just gymshark but the gym sharp lifting
events that we put on so yeah keep
training hard training smart of course
having a whole lot of freaking fun
Inspire the people who are you know
willing to listen and if they don't keep
doing it anyway and just having that
smile no matter what man Phil I
appreciate you thank you mate thank you
if you enjoyed that episode with Phil
then press here for a full length
two-hour podcast episode with Mr Olympia
classic physique Chris Bumstead go on
press it